نسبه الشباب في تونس تشهد تراجعا كبيرا
مقابل ارتفاع نسبه الكهول والشيوخ في
البلاد ظاهره التهمه السكاني هذه باتت
تهدد المجتمع والذي كان يشهد
فتوه سكانيا
فالخبراء يؤكدون على تراجع نسب الفئات
العمريه الشبابيه مقابل ارتفاع عدد الشيوخ
فقد اصبح عدد الذين تتجاوز اعمارهم من 65
عاما 800000 حاليا مع التوقعات ببلوغ
العدد نحو المليونين بعد 20 عاما ويبعز
الخبراء السبب الى سياسات الدوله لتحديد
النسل وهو امام شانه ان يؤدي الى اختلال
الانظمه الصحيه والتامينات الاجتماعيه
عاما سياسه تحديد النسل والتي تشجع على
الاكتفاء بثلاثه اطفال كحضن اقصى وتوفر
للنساء تسهيلات في الحصول على وسائل منع
الحمل وتعتبر نسبه النمو السكاني في تونس
الادنى في العالم العربي وتضاه الدول
الاوروبيه مزيد مع احلام ابن العبدلي من
تونس
[موسيقى]
التحرم السكاني في تونس في تزايد مستمر
تشير ارقامنا رسميه الى ان 10% من السكان
يتجاوز عمرهم ال 60 سنه وتؤكد ذات المصادر
على ان هذه النسبه قد تشهد ارتفاعا خلال
السنوات القادمه ابن المتوقع ان تصل الى
20 بالمئه مما يستوجب اتخاذ الاحتياطات
اللازمه
[موسيقى]
البركه
ويطلقون عليهم الغابه تقدير كثيره من
بينها سيدي وليله
تبدو الحياه في اعينها بعد هذه الرحله من
العمر
[موسيقى]
اللي تعدوا
وفات زعما يرجع
[موسيقى]
يتزوج
من العاشره في المياه تونس
في مزاد البساطه بتاع الناس زيد ما كانتش
بل تكميل كل الخير قديمه
شنو
هديه منها
[موسيقى]
انسان
اه
ويعود قلبي
كسلانه مربربه تونس
رغم انها معروفه بمجتمعاتها الفتيه الا ان
المنطقه العربيه تشهد تحولا ديمغرافيه
عميقا فبحسب تقارير الامم المتحده فان عدد
المسلمين في المنطقه العربيه سوف تتجاوز
اعداد الاطفال بحلول عام 2050 واليكم
المزيد من الارقام
قدرت نسبه الاشخاص الذين تروحوا اعمالهم
بين الستين عاما وما فوق بحوالي سبعه في
المئه في المنطقه العربيه ويتوقع ان ترتفع
هذه النسبه الى 18% بحلول عام 2050 وبحسب
احصائيات نشرها مركز
يتجاوز فيها عدد كبار السن ال10% من
اجمالي عدد السكان ماذا تتوقع ان تصل الى
اكثر من ثلاثه عشر في المئه بحلول لعام
2030 وبحلول عام 2030 سيلحق لبنان بتونس
يحتل المركز الاول ضمن فئه الدول التي
تتميز بتقدم اعمال سكانها اي ست تشكل نسبه
كبار السن 15% اما في المغرب والجزائر
وليبيا ومصر فنسبه الاشخاص المسنين في هذه
الدول تصل الى 8% وبحر لعام 2030 سوف
ترتفع نسبه الى 9.3
السعودي يتوقع ان تزيد نسبه كبار العمر
فيها من ثلاثه في المئه الى اكثر من سبعه
سنين عام 2030 وتصميم ضمن فئه الدول التي
تشهد نموها باعمال سكانها